there is a very important project at the
heart of the non house and that is high
speed too and I think if the
Conservative government or a future
conservative leader kills off high speed
too then that would be an enormous
betrayal of the north of England it
needs to go alongside the railway lines
across the north east west lines but you
know successful governments build things
they built cross rail they build Canary
Wharf that build the m25 unsuccessful
governments kill projects and if the
Conservatives kill off high speed - then
I think they'll face electoral oblivion
in this part of the country and rightly
so it was nearly two years ago that you
described tourism as a dead woman
walking and that was immediately after
that snap election you said that you
thought she would be forced to resign
almost immediately and yet we're here
nearly two years on and she's still go
in you called that wrong didn't you what
my observation was that she'd lost her
majority in the general election she
called and she would never regain it and
she won't be a lame-duck Prime Minister
and I afraid that has been borne out by
events eventually the party has to
confront the truth which is it needs a
new leader it needs a new agenda it
needs to win over supporters who have
disappeared from it and it needs to make
an appeal to urban metropolitan Britain
that has currently turned their back on
conservatism and if that's the case if
that continues to be the trend and there
won't be a Conservative government why
do you think she's hanging on in there
do you think it's because she's trying
to protect her own legacy or is she
trying to govern in the national
interest I mean what do you think it is
well I think Teresa made obviously
really wants to deliver her brexit deal
but she has not got the numbers to do
that and all she's got left is hoping
that Jeremy Corbyn a person who she
every day says is unfit for national
office to come to a rescue to keep her
in national office and that is not in my
mind a successful plan for a prime
minister you think you should stand down
well either I I don't know how much long
the conservative body will give her that
I would find it extremely hard if we got
to the Conservative Party conference and
there was still tourism a giving the
leaders speech I think we are going to
know in the next couple of weeks whether
there's any prospect of a deal between
Jeremy Corbyn and Theresa May and
whether the Labour Party is going to
rescue Premiership once it's clear that
they're not going to rescue the
Premiership I don't really see the point
of going on and there aren't brexit
negotiations it's just that Theresa May
can't and the government don't want to
break off the talks because that would
be the admission that they have run out
of any options you don't think it's
going to happen I heard that you had
said to someone why would a Corbin he
wants to be in government save a
drowning prime minister why would you
throw her a lifeline isn't that your
view well I won't do that look the
incentives on an opposition are to
replace the government because you think
generally you'd do a better job and so I
think any opposition leader would be
very hard pressed to rescue a dying
Prime Minister I think there's a point
where you have to ask yourself as a
political party how many more elections
are we going to lose so we lost the
majority in 2017 we got hammered in the
local elections this month and now we've
got these European elections where it's
quite possible that the conservative
body for the first time in its long and
distinguished history is going to come
forth in a national poll and essentially
there's a responsibility on the current
members of parliament and indeed the you
know supporters in the country to do
something about that and it's within
their hands you know there's you can't
just say there's all beyond my control
if you remember the cabinet you have a
responsibility and I as it happened I
was giving them any advice I would
suggest to them individually if they
want to lead fortune favors the brave in
these leadership contests just one other
thing if we zoom out on you and where
the countries aren't in terms of both
austerity and then the brexit referendum
on the back of it I was wondering
whether it made you feel a bit
comfortable or queasy that you played
such a high-stakes game while running
the country and that backfired and it's
caused all this chaos and division I
mean if I were if it were me I would I
think feel quite bad about that well I
do feel bad by the referendum I mean I
didn't want a referendum but I was part
of a team and we agreed to have a
referendum and indeed it was widely
supported and supported by across the
different political parties and we went
had a referendum but I didn't want to
have a referendum and then I did
everything I could
campaigned with everything I had to try
and persuade Britain to stay in the EU
but of course I feel a responsibility
for that